SEAN ASKAY: Hi there.
Thanks for coming out.
My name is Sean Askay, and I'm
a developer advocate here at
Google, as well as the
tech-lead for KML.
I'm here with Mano Marks
today, who's
also a developer advocate.
And we're going to be
talking about KML--
high-performance KML, and
some other cool things.
So on the screen, this is an
embedded Google Earth plugin,
and this is actually a KML Tour
that I'm using to animate
some polygons.
We'll talk more about
that in a second.
So a quick overview of what
we're going to talking about.
I'll give a very brief intro
to what KML is, then I'll
start talking about data
visualization using KML.
And then Mano will take over
and talk about developer
environments for
KML authoring.
And then KML rendering and maps
API and using KML with
Fusion Tables.
So a really brief
intro to KML.
Keyhole Markup Language was
developed at Keyhole before
the company was acquired
by Google.
It's basically a data language
that represents spacial data
and styling.
Kind of loosely like HTML
and CSS is to the web.
KMLs can be static files that
you can serve off of your
server or run locally
on your machine.
It can also be generated
dynamically via web services
and served to Google
Earth and Maps.
Google gave KML to the Open
Geospacial Consortium in 2008.
It's now an open standard used
by Google's Geo Tools and a
bunch of other third-party
tools as well.
And at last count, there's well
over a billion KML files
out there on the internet.
They're not all necessarily
interesting.
Unfortunately, most of the ones
out there look like this.
Basically, this is my house.
So here's the KML for a very
simple placemark, rocket ship,
description "goodbye world"
and some coordinates.
And this is what it looks
like in Google Earth.
I want to talk about a lot more
exciting things than just
point placemarks, specifically
data visualization.
I'm going to speak to
thematic mapping--
how to take data and visualize
it on the globe.
And then also talk about things
like GPS data and
tracking objects through
time and space.
So in a little more detail,
I'll be talking about 3D
extruded polygons, using a new
KML tag called altitude
offset, which makes it a lot
easier to create these
three-dimensional polygons.
Then we'll talk about animating
those polygons with
Google Earth Tours.
And then I'll switch to the
objects in motion GPS stuff,
and talk a little bit about gx
tracks and then finally talk
about bringing in a real-time
data feed to update GPS tracks
on a client.
The basic things here are
interesting new ways of
visualizing data, and then how
to keep it updated and fresh,
and then how to animate it.
So thematic mapping is basically
taking information
with a geographic context, like
Census population data or
demographics, and then
visualizing it on a map.
So here we have two examples.
One is showing some 3D spheres
using 3D sketchup models that
are scaled in proportion to some
data value, and the other
one here are these 3D extruded
polygons, which I'll be
talking about first.
So basically before we
introduced the gx altitude
offset tag, you had to specify
an altitude for every single
for vertex in the polygon, which
is kind of redundant.
It wastes a lot of space and
makes it very difficult to do
animations and updates
on those features.
Now with the altitude offset
tag, altitude is globally set
for the entire feature.
So here's a little code to show
you what a placemark with
a polygon looks like.
This is way we used to do it,
where you had the altitude
values after the longitude
and latitude for
every single vertex.
Now we basically can specify,
like I said, altitude offset
at a global level, and that
cascades down to all of the
placemarks underneath.
So I'm going to give you a
little demo of what you can do
with these types
of animations.
And the question here is what
can you do with Google Earth?
I basically spent the weekend
digging through Census
records, American Community
Survey records, state and
county polygon maps, and then
used Fusion Tables, Google
Refine, Google Charts
API, Python, using a
library called pyKML.
And a weekend I would rather
spend outside to
do some cool stuff.
So we're going to essentially
show you some live demos that
look a little bit like this.
So here's Google Earth.
I'm going to load the
KML that I made.
It's enormous.
It's about 40 megabytes
uncompressed, because there's
so much data.
This is pretty simple.
Mouse over.
You can see polygons
for each state.
As you zoom in, we fade to
county borders, so I can mouse
over and get each of
the county names.
Zoom in further and then those
will fade out and I'm left
with these white lines
undermarking the
edges of the counties.
So this isn't all that
interesting by itself, but I
can use a Google Earth Tour to
do some animations with it.
A Google Earth Tour is basically
a set of camera
flight pads and animations
that alter the content.
So I'm going to start
off one of these.
The first data set we're going
to look at are the percentage
of kids in each state that are
lacking health care, health
insurance, from 1987 to 2009.
And as you can see, these
are all moving around.
I can pause the tour.
When I mouse over it, I now have
the name of the state,
and it's a little hard to read,
but the percentage of
kids in that state for
that year that
don't have health insurance.
I can click on it, and then
using the Charts API, I'm
rendering this out over time.
So here we're looking at 2003
and the value is 19.4.
I can hit play and we'll
continue with the tour.
I can pause it, I can play with
the time slider, drag it
back and forth to any particular
date and then zoom
around and check things out.
And I'll note that Massachusetts
is the best
state in the nation for health
care for kids, so go
Massachusetts.
It'd be interesting to do a
mash-up with the red and blue
states on this as well,
I kind of wonder
if you'd see anything.
So that's this tour.
Let's take a look
at another one.
We're going to look at
percentage of houses that are
lacking complete indoor
plumbing.
Going back to the 1940s, a lot
of people in the states didn't
have indoor plumbing.
Here, Texas has 62%
of the households
without household plumbing.
I hit play.
And then each year, as you might
imagine, that drops.
Alaska popped up in the
background because we didn't
have data for Alaska in 1940.
And then we finish in 1990,
where almost the entire
country now has indoor
plumbing.
And then there's the graph.
One last data set I'll show is
looking at population data on
a county level.
So I'm going to zoom in to
California and I'm going to
hit play on that.
This is the biggest tour.
There's a lot of polygons, so
my little laptop has trouble
with this sometimes.
I also decided to take out the
smooth transitions with the
extruded polygons and just
snap them to different
altitudes, which helps improve
in performance.
So again, surprise, surprise,
Los Angeles is growing like
crazy, and you can also
see the Bay Area
picking up here as well.
I can zoom out, I can
pick one, check out
the data for it.
There's LA.
Or fly anywhere else in
the country and check
out the data there.
Whoops.
Let's go to Chicago.
So one of the interesting things
I noticed about this
data set with Chicago
was maybe suburban
sprawl popping up.
So I'm going to restart
this animation.
This is Cook County, I believe,
which is where
Chicago is.
And this will come online.
So as you imagine, Chicago, a
big city, lots of people.
It keeps going up and
up and up and up.
But I think in the '60s and
'70s it actually starts to
drop a little bit.
And you'll notice that as it's
dropping, these other counties
around it are starting
to pick up.
So I'm not an expert in the
region, but this might be an
example of suburban sprawl.
So maybe you can see with a data
set like this when you're
viewing it in three-dimensional
space.
So let's turn this off and head
back to talk about how
this is done.
So we basically want to animate
a polygon in the
context of a tour using the
animate update tag.
So here's a very simple
placemark.
We specify a polygon.
There's that altitude offset
and a bunch of coordinates
which I'm not showing you.
And elsewhere in the same file
I have a KML Tour, which
defines these animations and
these camera motions.
And here you can see, over the
course of three seconds, we're
going to change that
altitude--
well, to 1,000.
That should be 100.
So what you'll see in
the next slide is--
that was actually supposed
to be 10,000--
that the polygon now
gets raised higher.
We add an extra zero here,
and off we go.
So this is basically how you
would do an animated update to
extrude that polygon to
a different altitude.
You can do more than just
extruding polygons and making
them taller.
You can actually interplay
between any values in KML.
So let's check out
another demo.
So this is just kind
of a visual--
no particular data
attached to it.
But it's kind of cool-looking.
We're going to fly in, and
here we have these circle
polygons that are expanding
in time.
So the original polygon is a
small circle, and then I'm
saying over three seconds,
changed to these coordinates,
which are a bigger set of
coordinates, a bigger ring.
So that's going to basically
make these
animate and expand out.
And again, this time, you notice
the camera was moving
with the tour because I
have recorded a flight
path with it as well.
All right?
Another way of doing somatic
maps-- and I'm going to rush
through this a little
bit so we can
get to the GPS session--
is to use 3D sketchup
models instead.
So here's sketchup.
We've got a model
of a cell phone.
This screenshot comes from
thematicmapping.org, an
awesome website.
They have an API for creating
thematic maps, although the
animations aren't done
quite the same way
as I'm showing here.
Basically you have
a placemark.
You specify the location, the
scale, and the model file.
Just like with the
previous example,
here's my original model.
I can bring in that KML Tour,
and I can say, hey, scale, I
want to extrude you.
I want to make you bigger
in the y-dimension
by a factor of 10.
So our new cell phone
gets a lot bigger.
The value here changes to
1,000, and off we go.
So the next thing I'm going to
talk about is GPS-type data
and what you can do with
that in Google Earth.
So let's do a couple quick demos
to show you what that
looks like.
I'm going to load some data.
So the entire Geo Team at Google
took an off-site field
trip not too long ago.
We all went to Lake Tahoe
and we all went skiing.
And we had a bunch of people
run around with GPS units,
which was pretty cool.
Which means that I can drag the
time slider, and you can
see all kinds of Googlers
running around the slopes,
skiing, snowboarding,
et cetera.
In addition to manipulating the
time slider manually, I
have a tour that will
do it for me.
And it'll do a camera path and
it'll do a nice advancement of
the times slider so we can
get a visualization here.
So this is me on
a dogsled ride.
So I'll fast-forward through a
bit of this and then you can
watch everybody going
up the ski slopes
and then skiing down.
One other example of this is
taking a 3D model and actually
showing that in the context
of a GPS track.
So a couple of years back, I
made a tour for the Apollo 11
landing on the moon.
And now is when I regret--
OK.
The internet is fine.
I was worried there
for a second.
I created a tour that basically
shows the path of
the Apollo 11 lander coming
in to land on the moon.
Let's turn off some other layers
here, keep the imagery,
keep the terrain.
So back then, we didn't have
this GX GPS track feature.
So I basically had to create
animated updates to move that
model segment-by-segment
along the path.
Now, fortunately, I don't
have to do that.
I can actually just drag the
time slider if we know when
and where that model was.
We'll zoom out a little bit,
like that, and you
can bring it in.
So I can make a tour animating
the lander a lot easier now
just using this GX
track feature.
So let's talk about
how that's done.
The way this used to be done is
people would basically take
a bunch of placemarks or a bunch
of lines, they put a
time stamp or a time span
feature on it, and you would
play with the time slider.
And you're essentially
duplicating this same object
over and over and over and
over again to animate it.
Now we have a single placemark,
a single feature
through time and space.
It's the GX tag we'll
show in a second.
This currently only works
in Google Earth 5.2.
So you're not going to be able
to do this in Google Maps--
obviously, you can't do 3D stuff
or tours in Maps either.
As I said, you can use 2D models
or 3D models, and as
I'll talk about in a second,
you can add extended data,
additional attribute data,
correlated to the time and the
path of the object.
Like if you're riding a bike,
heartbeat, or if you're
driving car, RPMs.
So basically the way this looks
in the KML-- it's a set
of parallel arrays.
You've got a bunch of when
statements that define time
stamps for each segment
along the path.
You've got coordinates
that say where you
were at that time.
And if you're using a 3D
model, you specify the
different rotations
of that model, the
orientation of that model.
This can be a little hard to
author because it's a parallel
array, and if you're writing
code, it'd be nice to kind of
iterate through each different
time step.
So as long as you don't tell
the Schema Monster, you can
basically interleave these.
As one schema validates, but
Google Earth will read it just
fine, and if you save it back
out, it will put everything in
its proper order.
So let's take a look
at a little bit of
demo, another demo.
Looking at a bike track of a
coworker who took heartbeat
data along the way.
So we're going to switch
back to Google Earth.
Go, internet.
All right.
And then I'm going to
load the bike track.
We're going to fly down here.
So Peter's in the
room, actually.
This is his track.
And you'll see that I can click
anywhere along the track
and get his heart rate at
that particular point.
I can also right click
on the track and
show elevation profile.
This will basically show a
graph of his speed, the
altitude at the time, and his
heart rate, in this case, as
an additional data set.
So here is his heart rate during
the course of the trip.
So let's look at how
you do that in KML.
So again, this part
is the same.
A bunch of when and cord
statements defining when and
where the person was,
or the object was.
Then you're using the extended
data tag and you're specifying
a simple array called heart
rate, and another parallel
array that goes and correlates
with each of these.
So this is what allows you to
basically take any variable
you want and sync it up
with the GPS track.
So that's kind of cool,
but I want to show
something even cooler.
Which is what if you wanted to
stream in real-time data?
Have a data feed come in and
basically push the locations
of an object to the client.
So let's take a look at that.
So I was in Kenya some time
back and I had the luck of
going in a Cessna with an old,
salty pilot, who took us on
this kind of crazy tour
around Mount Kenya,
which is north of Nairobi.
So what's happening here is I'm
fetching each segment of
this track a piece at a time.
So the initial file only had the
initial little piece that
you saw, and each additional
network fetch that I make, I
am grabbing additional data,
injecting it into the track.
So doing something like this,
you could basically pull in
real-time feeds of Google
latitude data.
If you have any other devices
that are streaming a location,
you could visualize it like
this, a segment at a time, and
push out the real-time
locations, and the track in
between now and the
last update.
So we're going to land here in
a second, and then I'll show
you guys how this is
done in the KML.
So conceptually what's happening
here is we have two
network links.
A network link is a KML feature
that basically fetches
from a URL to KML.
So the first network link
fetches an initial file that
just contains maybe the first
little segment, maybe up to
the current location
of the object.
Then there's a second network
link that hits the server and
says, well, give me any updates
that have happened
since I last checked
in with you.
So here you've got Google
Earth, here's
your initial request--
this can either be static files,
which is what I showed
you a second ago, or it could
be a live web service.
And then the update's going to
come through that second
connection to your
web service.
So here is kind of a zoom of
that left panel that I was
showing you a second ago.
Here's the network link
to the original file.
That fetched the initial track
and then I have underneath it
a second network link that
fetches the updates.
So this is how it would look.
This is how you'd make it.
Here's your placemark.
And instead of using a regular
track, I'm going to use a
multitrack.
Since GPS data tends
to be segmented--
you turn your GPS on or off--
and you want to maybe visualize
your entire trip,
you can actually combine
multiple tracks into a single
placemark feature.
So I've got a single multitrack
here, with the
first segment of
data, Sean T1.
And I should mention that we
grabbed that from maybe
GPS.py, which is our initial
file fetcher,
first network link.
Then I hit web slash feed.py,
which gives the updates.
And that's what this
looks like.
This is using what's called
a network link control.
It's another feature of KML.
It basically says, hey,
update this item.
It's a little similar to
the animated update
you guys saw before.
This is actually a precursor
to Tours.
This was just basically created
to basically stream
content to a client and
then change it on
the fly like this.
The other thing that we do
here is we send with this
second file a cookie, which is
appended onto the end of the
URL, which says, hey, this is
the last time I got data.
I've been giving you data
up to this point.
And you'll see how that's
used in a second.
So what's going to happen is
this track is going to get
bumped up over here, so now we
have track number two, we can
see our track was updated.
That last parameter was appended
to the feed URL such
that the next time you fetch,
your server can say, hey, OK,
I know that he had everything
up through this date, so now
I'm going to update him with
everything through this date
and give him a new track
that contains all
that additional data.
So anyway, in summary, here's
what we talked about.
A little bit about thematic
mapping and using these 3D
extruded polygons with the
altitude offset tag, which
makes it a lot easier to author
the content, and also
allows us to make these time
animations using Google Earth
Tours using the animated
update tag.
And then I just finished the
section on objects in motion--
looking at GS track as a feature
to look in GPS data,
and then how to use the updates
tag with the network
link control to basically push
new data into that track.
So I just launched a new blog
today at unchartable.com, and
I'm going to start talking about
KML techniques like this
in the future.
And with that, I'm going to
hand it over to Mano.
MANO MARKS: Thanks, Sean.
Hi.
Am I on?
I'm on.
OK.
Hey.
Last session of the day,
pretty exciting.
I hope you all are having
a great day today.
Sean dared me to
make this joke.
The Android people are giving
out tablets and the Geo people
are giving out free maps.
So.
Yeah.
All right.
Some of you laughed
at any rate.
OK, so Sean and I are developer
advocates, which
means this is our job, right?
A big part of our job is to go
out and talk to developers
about actually doing code and
the process of doing that.
And we find that a lot of
developers ask us specific
questions about developer
environments.
Like what are the kinds of
things that you use to
actually do your coding?
So I'm going to toss a whole
bunch of ideas and things that
Sean and I do at you, but
mostly, again, as all coding
is, it's really going to be
questions of personal
preference.
There is no right single
development environment for
creating KML.
So the things that I'm going
to talk about briefly are
editors, validators, particular
programming
languages, and also mention
some open-source libraries
that might be really
useful for you.
So particularly for the
programming editor, this is
something of a personal
choice.
Generally, your options are
some sort of integrated
development environment or
just basic text editors.
And I'm particularly fond of
vi, and of course Sean is
particularly fond of Emacs.
So we have the classic, older
hacker kind of conflict, even
though he's a lot younger
than I am.
And some different ideas of
the different things.
They one place that we come
together is on Notepad++, it's
a nice Windows environment.
We've got some nice scripts
dialing and
some basic text editing.
And if somebody could turn off
their phone ringer, thank you.
And then, of course, some people
do prefer Eclipse or
Visual Studios, which has some
integrated XML editing
environments.
Personally, I just go with the
classic VI because it's pretty
much everywhere.
Sorry, that's a little dig.
Anyway so XML validators.
So XML is a document
format, right?
And the scale of things that
we're talking about here,
you're not really hand-editing
KML anymore, right?
High-performance KML, you're
generating this KML
programmatically But there are
times when you want to check
whether it's a valid output and
you want to actually do
that by hand.
And I'm particularly fond of
Oxygen, which is a nice
cross-platform Java-based
validator.
XMLSpy is something a lot
of people are fond of.
jEdit is something that Sean
is fond of, and of course,
it's actually, I
believe, free.
And Notepad++ has some basic
validation stuff built in.
But, of course, you can also
directly validate using a
number of different libraries,
the classic being libXML.
And then a bunch of
language-specific ones.
And then there's some
KML-specific specific
libraries that helpful. pyKML,
as Sean mentioned, and LibKML.
And then for programming
languages, I think Sean and I
are both most fond of Python as
a language for doing this
kind of coding.
Easy to get started
on your scripting.
And it's got support for
libraries like LibKML, pyKML,
GDAL, OGR, those
sort of things.
And a couple things that
you need to take into
consideration when you're
thinking about what
programming languages that
you're working on, is think
about what your production
environment's going to
actually look like.
So many of you are going to be
very comfortable on your
laptop or in your desktop doing
some coding in whatever
scripting language you
want to be doing.
You've got your Rubys on
Rails environment,
or blah, blah, blah.
Whatever your particular kind of
thing that you've got, but
you have to think about how
that's going to translate into
a hosted environment, how it's
going to translate it if
you're going to be pushing
that out somebody.
So it's often good to sort
of start from that
as a starting location.
Things to think about that might
not occur to you right
away are things like Google
App Management doesn't
currently allow you to support
C++ libraries, anything but
pure Python or Java.
So those are the kind of
decisions you're going to need
to look at before you actually
get started when you're
creating a large-scale
application.
And if you're, for instance,
say, pulling from a database
certain programming languages
has had better integration
with different databases, so
the classics being PHP and
MySQL are pretty
closely linked.
There's tons of code that help
you pull that data out there.
And if you're doing something
like interacting with the data
API, like Fusion Tables, what
are the client libraries that
you'll need?
OK.
And just to give a quick
call-out out to pyKML.
You may be familiar with LibKML,
which was actually
produced by Google engineers and
is used in some production
environments within Google.
pyKML is a bit lighter-weight.
It supports primarily the core
elements of KML and it's
written in Python, so it's got
a very Pythonic interface.
So I just wanted to show you
this as an example here.
This is a pretty simple way of
creating KML documents, which
is one of those core container
elements for KML, adding in
Atom and putting in the links
that you're preserving,
attribution, and then creating
a placemark.
You may recognize 0, 0 as Null
Island in the old Myst game.
It's also where a lot of KML
with poorly-configured
latitude and longitude ends
up automatically--
this spot off the west
coast of Africa.
So if you're always wondering
why there's this big cluster
of things--
it like, anything that Google
Earth doesn't actually know
how to place, it's going to
either place it there or
entirely off-screen.
So I like to use that
in my examples.
OK.
So that's just a simple
pyKML example.
So I want to switch gears here
and talk about the Maps API
because Maps actually
deals with KML in a
very different way.
I'm going to start with
showing you some
capabilities here.
So this is a USGS KML file
overlaid onto a Google Maps
API application.
And you'll see that the
earthquakes are styled
different colors based
on their intensity.
And I can click here and you'll
see to the right here,
I've got the actual data there
from the placemark that I
clicked on.
Now, you may notice that it's
not actually pulling it into
an info window, and that's
because I've done some code to
prevent it from doing that.
So I just wanted to show you
this to demonstrate that you
can do something a bit
interesting, which is you can
actually load it in as a
clickable raster overlay.
So how many of you were in the
Fusion Tables talk earlier?
OK.
All of you.
Awesome.
This is like the Geo diehards
here, right?
OK.
So in that talk, James McGill
described how Fusion Tables
will render all your placemarks
into basically 40
tiles and place them
onto a map.
Well, KML goes through a
very similar renderer.
Basically these are all rendered
as a clickable raster
overlay to increase
performance.
So you can put in quite a bit
more placemarks in KML than
you can if you were loading
this up using--
you were creating a Javascript
objects.
And it's created using this
clickable raster overlay.
But once you click on it, you
actually actively get data out
of it that can be captured and
then manipulated and used.
OK.
So people often ask me about
this process and how it works.
You basically create this KML
layer object, and I'm going to
show you the actual code for
this in a minute, but this is
the particular process.
Place the KML file
on a server.
You create this KML layer
object in your Maps API
application, and then the Maps
API let's Google servers know
where that is.
Google servers go out, fetch
the KML file, and render it
into this right-clickable raster
overlay, which they
pass back to your Maps
API application.
So this is why--
and the question people always
ask me is, why can't I put
this KML file on my computer?
Or why can't I put a password
into this to prevent other
people from getting
access to it?
It's because you can't pass
that password onto Google
server to let it know.
It has to actually go out, fetch
the KML, render it, and
then pass it back.
So any KML object used in the
Maps API must be rendered onto
a public server.
OK.
I want to go back to the
limitations in a second, but I
wanted to show you the actual
code, since I actually
talked about it.
It's very simple.
Here you've got this
KML layer you just
created, pass it the URL.
Here, I'm passing options to
it and here I have the
suppressed info window, it's
true, and I set it to the map.
And this should actually have
my options in there.
It looks like that
got left out.
And then here, I'm adding an
event listener to the KML
layer on the click that
take the texts
from the KML feature.
So when I click on it, it is
able to capture that future
data, get the description, and
then it shoves it into a DIV.
So that's just a very simple
explanation of what was
happening before and why it
wasn't showing up as an info
window, it's showing
up in the side.
So let me talk about some
the limitations here for
using the Maps API.
So as Sean mentioned, we don't
support full KML in
the Google Maps API.
And the reason for this kind
of two-fold, here.
One is, it's 2D environment,
right?
You don't have a way of
representing a 3D model, you
don't have a way of
representing elevation directly--
there's a lot of different
things that you don't have.
And the other is that this
process of having the server
load the file and then send it
back to the browser means that
you've got lots of interaction
between servers and clients
and stuff going on.
So there's very big performance
considerations.
So we have a relatively small
file size for geographic data.
That 10 megabytes, maximum.
And a limitation in
the particular KML
that's actually supported.
And in this case, it's primarily
the geometry data.
We don't support very many
of the extensions
that Google has added.
So the GX tours, and the tracks,
and all those things
that Sean was really excited
about because they're
incredibly powerful
visualization tools, we don't
support those in Maps just
because of these limitations.
And also for security reasons
and because we're passing this
off to a Javascript application
that may be
sitting on a different server--
so you noticed that
file that I actually loaded,
the USGS file, was actually
loaded directly from
the USGS.com.
So since it's being loaded from
a different site, we have
to actually be careful about
cross-site scripting and all
that sort of thing.
So it'll scrape out Javascript
and Flash that's in the
description balloons.
So these are some of the kind of
considerations that you'll
need to think about when you're
creating KML for the
Google Maps API.
And of course, it has
to be on a public
server with no password.
By the way, that scraping out
the Javascript and Flash, you
can put that back in by
capturing the click events and
creating a new info window,
if you want.
OK.
So those are the major things
I wanted to talk about
for the Maps API.
So things to be thinking about
in these considerations is--
the primary thing is, think
about producing separate KML
that's optimized for Maps when
you are producing KML.
You have a set of data that's
highly optimized for Earth and
a set of data that's highly
optimized for Maps.
And you can do this dynamically,
depending on the
client that's querying it.
You can spend parameters to
your network links or to
whatever that are loading the
data to change them if it's a
Maps API application.
OK.
So most of you were in the
Fusion Tables talk, so I'm not
going to actually go as deep
into this as I was going to
because it doesn't seem like
it would help to repeat it.
But I just want to talk about
some basic things that you can
do with Fusion Tables.
So that these are captured.
And anybody who's watching the
video, take a look at the
Fusion Tables talk, as well.
So this is a simple Maps API app
that I wrote with a very
simple Fusion Table.
I was a historian in
a former life.
And the idea here is that the
boundaries of Poland have
changed pretty dramatically over
the years, and so I just
wrote one that captured that and
rendered these on a map.
So you'll see here in 1492,
these where the
boundaries of Poland.
In 1650, that was where the
boundaries of Poland--
In 1815, it actually goes
away when Prussia and
Russia split Poland.
And I believe Austria actually
took a piece of it.
And in 1920 these are
the boundaries.
And 1945, you see they're the
current boundaries there.
So the things to note about this
is this is all done with
KML that is loaded into
Fusion Tables.
And what Fusion Tables does, as
you know from the previous
talk, you load up tabular data
and it pushes it into Fusion
Tables, and then you just
click on visualize map
and you get a map.
So the point here, though,
is Fusion Tables
supports KML in here.
So when you're creating KML
and you're uploading it to
Fusion Tables, things to be
aware of, that it's a smaller
subset of KML than even
the Maps API supports.
It's basically just
the geometries.
So what it does is it takes the
KML file and it strips out
all of the styling that you've
done in your KML.
So any styling that you're
producing, you don't bother
with it to create it.
And it just strips out the
geometries and then it takes a
look at the extended
data elements.
Extended data is where you can
create basically name-value
pairs of data for your
KML features.
So it then takes those extended
data and turns that
into columns.
So things that you had in the
description and the name I
think are also transferred,
and then
nothing else comes along.
So that includes things
like time stamp
and time span elements.
OK.
So the integration with the
Maps API, as you will know
from the previous session, is
essentially one line of code.
You can do additional things,
as we've announced today, in
styling these layers as
they come through.
And this is, again, just a
summary of some of the things
to do with our KML support.
Again, itr renders this
clickable raster, much like
the KML layer does, and you
can upload files up to 100
megabytes in a single file
into Fusion Tables--
although a single table can
actually be much larger.
You can programmatically add
data to files to get it up to
250 megabytes.
That's for a single
Gmail account.
So this is your basic code
sample for integrating with
the Maps API.
Here we've got a Fusion Table
layers, object, you pass in a
table ID, and then you can
optionally add in a query.
And this is from this Poland
demo that I just showed you.
Select geometry from table ID
where year equals year, and
set the Layer 2 amount.
OK, so that's all we have
on that right now.
We are happy that you all are
here and we'd really like to
take some questions.
We would ask that if you have a
question that you come up to
one of the mics so that the
questions can be recorded.
SEAN ASKAY: And a couple
other things as well.
MANO MARKS: I guess
we can both be on.
SEAN ASKAY: Apologies to Mano.
I screwed up you sample.
I was converting all our slides
to HTML5 this morning
and I got a bad copy-paste.
MANO MARKS: No worries.
SEAN ASKAY: If you guys have
feedback about this talk, we'd
love to hear it at
SpeakerMeter.
The URL's down there.
Tell us how bad or
well we did.
And questions?
AUDIENCE: Our organization's
running Esri, and they have a
lot of jurisdictional data.
It's highly accurate, it's
very up to date.
When I get a supervisorial
district KML file that they're
going to generate off a
shapefile, it's huge.
Do you have any way of
simplifying it to make it a
smaller KML?
Shrink it a bit?
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
So there's a number of
techniques that you can use.
AUDIENCE: A mechanism?
Yeah.
MANO MARKS: The classic one
to use is regenation.
Regenation basically breaks down
your file into simpler--
say you're dealing
with polygons.
It'd be a simpler polygon when
viewed from a distance, and
more complex polygons
for portions of your
data at lower points.
SEAN ASKAY: You might look at
Fusion Tables, if you didn't
already attend that talk.
If you do convert your shapefile
to KML, you can put
up to a million characters in
each cell in Fusion Tables.
So as long as one polygon
doesn't have more than a
million characters for the
geometry, toss them in Fusion
Tables, and we actually do quite
well with really large
geometries, really
fine detail.
The other thing is, do you
really need all that
detail in the KML?
AUDIENCE: Probably not.
SEAN ASKAY: In which case, I
would recommend using Esri
software that you
have already.
There are polygon simplification
tools in ArcGIS
that will simplify those
polygons down and make them a
lot easier to manage and deal
with in Google Earth.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANO MARKS: So one additional
point on that is actually Josh
[? Litmey, ?]
who's in the audience, wrote
an application called Shape
Escape, which allows you to
upload a shapefile directly to
Fusion Tables.
It decomposes it, puts all the
features, and posts them using
the Fusion Tables API into
Fusion Tables, and it will
simplify any KML that's
too complex.
It'll simplify polygons that
have too many vertices.
SEAN ASKAY: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
A client asked me this question,
and I hope I gave
them the right answer.
If you go ahead and load KML
into Google Maps like that,
that URL I pass you, does that
end up in the Google search
engine anywhere?
In other words, could that data
then be found elsewhere?
MANO MARKS: So I don't--
SEAN ASKAY: Are you going
to repeat the question?
MANO MARKS: So the question is
if you create a KML layer
using a Maps API application,
does that URL then
get passed on to--
AUDIENCE: Elsewhere
in Google, yeah.
MANO MARKS: --To our web search
to or Map search to
allow it to be found
in some other spot?
No.
SEAN ASKAY: Yeah.
Not that I'm aware of.
I'd be shocked if it did.
So.
AUDIENCE: That's what
I told him.
That's the best we're
going to do is--
we'd all be surprised.
MANO MARKS: Does he
want it to be?
Was it [INTERPOSING VOICES]?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
That's the point.
You can't put in a password, but
I told him nobody's ever
going to find it.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
The other thing you might do if
you're really worried about
it is put in site map that
specifies don't call the
particular directory that
KML comes from.
SEAN ASKAY: I guess it all
depends on how you're passing
the URL on, as well.
Because if you're doing that
client-side on Javascript,
someone could look at your
page, like you say, and
actually fish for the URLs.
But if it's server-side or
something, or if you're
obscuring the way that URLs
pass, you'll be fine.
MANO MARKS: If you're really
concerned, you use Maps API
Premiere upload it to Fusion
Tables, and use the private
Fusion Table option for Premiere
that allow you to
keep your table private, but
still share it with the rest
of the world.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I had two questions.
First, when the last I looked,
I could not find a reasonable
pure Java API for writing KML.
I saw a number of JNI APIs but
those are harder to deploy and
harder to work with.
Oh, you're on Linux,
I'm on Windows.
Blah, blah, blah.
Is there a good pure Java
way to make KML?
MANO MARKS: Not to
my knowledge.
SEAN ASKAY: I'm not a
Java guy, so not to
my knowledge, no.
Unfortunately.
MANO MARKS: You might be able
to do something with--
essentially, KML
is XML, right?
So using the built-in libraries
to do it, you could
actually just
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
AUDIENCE: I could write a Java
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
in KML.
MANO MARKS: Exactly.
And then you could post it to
Google Code Hosting, so that
everybody could use it.
AUDIENCE: But how would
I get paid to do that?
MANO MARKS: And I think there's
a couple of people
waving their hands who
have some ideas--
AUDIENCE: Oh, you'll
pay me to do that.
MANO MARKS: --About that.
So.
And if they could come up--
yeah.
It shouldn't be that hard, but
at least one person may be
coming up to the mic to
announce one later.
So [INTERPOSING VOICES].
SEAN ASKAY: To repeat that
question, it was is there a
pure Javascript library
for creating KML.
MANO MARKS: Not Javascript.
SEAN ASKAY: Java.
LibKML, C++, but you could
probably do SWIG bindings to
Java, but that's not
made of Java.
MANO MARKS: And it it poses
cross-platform problems
because the SWIG bindings for
Windows don't work very well--
SEAN ASKAY: At least when Py
came out, that I was showing
earlier with Python, that's just
an extension of LibXML,
C++ as well, so.
Nevermind.
MANO MARKS: A pure Java solution
might be really
useful, for instance, in a Java
version of app engine.
AUDIENCE: My other question is
when I'm doing development on
my personal box behind a
firewall, is there a DEV mode
or something?
Where I could say, I've
got some KML.
I just want to post it
to a place and then
bring it right back.
Where I don't have to set up a
Sandbox and publish it on a
Sandbox with an URL.
I have the KML in memory
in Javascript.
Could somebody do something
with it?
MANO MARKS: You mean
for Maps API?
AUDIENCE: Yes, for Maps API.
MANO MARKS: So the question is
is there a way to load KML
into a development environment
on your personal laptop or
desktop or whatever without
having to post it to an
environment so that the Google
servers come and get it?
No.
AUDIENCE: Too bad.
MANO MARKS: No, there's not.
SEAN ASKAY: Google has to come
and get it, so if you can't
hit a server on your laptop--
MANO MARKS: That was the
point of the diagram
[INTERPOSING VOICES]--
AUDIENCE: DEV would even--
I would even send it to--
the Maps tiles don't load
if I'm not online.
I can be online.
What I want to do is be able to
post it to Google directly
and then have Google just send
it right back to me as tiles,
rather than putting it up in a
place and then waiting for you
to come get it.
That's harder for my firewall.
MANO MARKS: If you want do that,
you could use something
like Google Storage for
Developers or Google Code
Hosting to upload it there and
then grab the files off of
that using the KML layer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANO MARKS: So certainly
you could do that.
AUDIENCE: Puncha a hole
in the router.
MANO MARKS: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Punch a hole in your
router so it can see
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yes, punching a hole
in my router is what I don't
want to do.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
I never recommend punching in a
hole in your router so that
Google servers can come
in and and look at it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well I was just
going to say that I've
marshaled from a future
collection in Geo Tools into
and out of a KML.
So I think that's
possible still.
My question was about an element
in KML that would
allow me to take a georeferenced
image that I
already have, like say
a historical map.
I know the bounding box for it,
and just bring it up in
Google Earth.
Is that possible?
MANO MARKS: Mmm hmm.
SEAN ASKAY: There are a couple
different ways of doing it.
If you have a georeference
file, like a GeoTIFF.
If you have Google Earth Pro
or Google Earth Enterprise,
that'll directly import.
It'll convert it to a jpeg and
then display it for you.
There are also some regenatioN
options with that, if you have
really high resolution
rasters.
But there are a lot of
free tools, as well.
Goodle, or gDial, depending on
how we'd say it, is another
open-source library that will
tile stuff for you.
There's a tool called
gDial to Tiles.
It's Python-based and
it will convert it.
There's also MapTiler.
If you go to Maptiler.org, it's
a desktop app that will
take georeferenced images
and generate KML for it.
But not natively in KML.
There's no way to say, here's
my random raster proprietary
format, bring it in.
You actually have to
do a conversion
process to native KML.
AUDIENCE: To native KML.
But it will reference an image
file, like a gif or something,
and then there will
be bounding box
coordinates on it?
SEAN ASKAY: Yep.
Absolutely.
MANO MARKS: If you know the
bounding box and it's not a
super large file, you can just
load it using a ground overlay
element so that the core element
is ground overlay.
That's the thing that
you're looking for.
Large files, you
need to do some
regionation and tiling for.
SEAN ASKAY: You can talk
to us after and we can
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MANO MARKS: And there's
an article on the KML
documentation [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
answer the earlier question.
There is an API called Java API
for KML, or JAK, J-A-K.
And it's hosted on
Google Code.
It's kind of an early version,
but I've been using it for
about a year.
It has a few quarks but
it does the job.
MANO MARKS: That's great.
Java API for KML or JAK--
SEAN ASKAY: Hosted
on Google Code.
MANO MARKS: --And hosted
By the way, Sean and I go
to a lot of scientific
conferences as well.
There is a Fortran library
for creating KML.
Whatever language you're going
to ask about, there probably
will be something out there.
I'm not advocating Fortran as
a solution, but they say
there's lots of math libraries
out there for it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For the offset of
polygons, now it's altogether.
Can we go back to have the
regular one with points on
demand when we need it?
If we have slopes
on the polygons?
Different nodes have different
elevations?
SEAN ASKAY: Sure.
So if you put different
elevations at each individual
coordinate, the altitude offset
would just kind of
overwrite those.
It doesn't physically overwrite
them, it just
ignores them.
So if you were to just remove
that altitude offset, then all
that altitude data would
still be preserved in
the original polygon.
So.
MANO MARKS: Doesn't the altitude
or offset simply add
the altitude to each
of the vertices?
SEAN ASKAY: No.
I thought it--
well.
I think it just overides
it, but--
MANO MARKS: Hmm.
There seems to be some--
SEAN ASKAY: I can find
out for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So another one is if I have
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
shapefile with z elevation
for each node.
So is there a way to bring those
automatically with what
the elevation-- what the z value
for each one of them?
Is there something out
there that export
[INTERPOSING VOICES]?
MANO MARKS: If you convert a
shapefile directly to KML
using, as Sean says,
Goodle, as I say [?
G-D-A-L and as other people
say gDial, there's an
open-source set of libraries
that you can use, just a
command line, to do the
conversion, or you can do it
in Google Earth Pro.
So, yes.
And that will bring along
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
AUDIENCE: So Google Earth Pro,
when you import with it, it
brings in also the elevation
value, right?
For each node?
MANO MARKS: Yes.
SEAN ASKAY: It should, yeah.
And the question was, just to
repeat, if you have z data
values in your shapefile,
altitude values,
will those be converted?
And yeah, there are also
extensions for ArcGIS, like
Arc2Earth, that will
do export and they
may preserve z values.
So I look at some of those
converters as options.
MANO MARKS: And if you're
interested in that, Josh
[? Lidney ?]
and I are giving a talk tomorrow
afternoon on GIS in
Google Earth and Maps.
That's another talk.
And also the folks
from Arc2Earth
here in the Geo Sandbox.
So, yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there tools or
APIs essentially for creating
vector tiles?
I don't know if Google Maps for
web is using this, I know
that Google Maps for mobile
has started to use vector
tiles to save on bandwidth.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MANO MARKS: You mean to
create your own--
AUDIENCE: --tools that will
take KML and put it into
smaller [INTERPOSING VOICES].
MANO MARKS: To create your own
tiles as opposed to using our
KML layer or the Fusion
Table layer?
AUDIENCE: Well some vector tiles
as opposed to using the
image tiles.
MANO MARKS: Oh, I see.
So the question is are
there tools for
creating vector tiles?
Vector tiles, essentially for
KML, that's regionation.
That's actually a concept
that's been
around for a while.
But there's been a lot of people
experimenting with
passing vectors in the
same kind of--
the concept was the same, that
you're packaging it into these
tiles to a maps application
or to Google Earth.
I don't actually know of
anything specifically in that
area that's very good.
Do you know of anything?
SEAN ASKAY: Not so much
for Google products.
There's some open-source mapping
tools that kind of
have this concept of
tiled vector data.
And I want to say one of the
ArcGIS extensions, maybe it
was Arc2Earth, might do that.
One of the trick you run into is
if you're tiling a polygon,
you chop it up.
You tile it up.
And if you want like a border
along that polygon, now the
original polygon that's been
chopped has lines through the
cuts, right?
So at the moment, Google
Earth doesn't really
handle that very well.
It's something we'd be
interested in looking at.
But, yeah.
So I can look online, but
offhand, I can't think of
anything that works really
well for KML.
There's definitely a need for
that kind of functionality,
that kind of tool.
All right.
Any other questions?
Three minutes to spare.
Cool.
Thank you, guys.
Come up afterwards if you
have any questions.